jennifer lopez and alex rodriguez split
after
four years together calling off their
two-year engagement
a source tells e.t the couple decided
their relationship has run its course
saying quote jennifer felt like moving
forward to marriage wasn't right
recently alex's character has been
called into question and that didn't sit
right with jennifer
the couple will always have respect for
each other the two started dating in
spring of 2017
gushing over each other to et throughout
the years
we've been having a lot of fun and i've
been enjoying just spending time with
her
our kids her kids and we learn we have a
lot of fun with each other
we're very alike in many ways and i
think that's what makes it work and i
think that's why people
respond to the fact that we got together
we're like except i can't sing dance and
i don't look like her besides that we're
twins
we compliment each other in a in a
beautiful way and
i couldn't have asked for a better
partner in this we both
are so happy about
our lives right now and where we're at
professionally as well as personally you
know just things seem to be flowing in a
really beautiful way
we both have a lot of support for each
other and a lot of love for each other
and
you know so much has changed in a year
in a sense
for us for each of us individually
and we're just really happy it's a it's
a good time in march 2019
alex confirmed they were engaged when he
shared this photo to his instagram of a
massive sparkler with the caption
she said yes he's just the most
supportive
caring present partner
and i just you know i'm so grateful
for our life and our kids and this time
and i couldn't ask for a better person
to be by my side right now
the two were planning on getting married
in 2020 in italy but were forced to
postpone their nuptials due to the covet
19 pandemic
where did the wedding plans stand where
you know what can't share those deets
right now but just um not even between
just between
these girls maybe when those are not
rolling
we'll have you you'll probably be there
who knows uh we're gonna um
we're definitely talking about it and so
i can tell you that
in early february alex's name popped up
in an unexpected place
on bravo's southern charm tabloids
linked him to one of the show's stars
madison lacroix you were flying around
the country sleeping with
married men ex-mlb players that's what
you were doing during time
tell me you know why austin was in my
house because you weren't talking to him
you flew to miami to an xmlb
player major league baseball
a source told et at the time that alex
had never met madison and doesn't know
her
while madison told page six they never
met up but did claim
they've spoken on the phone alex and
jennifer last posted on social media
together in late february when a-rod
visited j-lo in the dominican republic
while she was filming a movie